[Applaudissements]
on a à detroit tentant par maguy à l'e3
j'ai grandi dans la musique c'est mon
univers
j'ai une dernière chanson pour vous ce
soir si tu m'avais dit quand j'étais
gamine car georges bosserait pour grease
davis c'est une légende
ça va j'ai pas la balle est bien s'il
veut être radiés resplendissante
je sais que tu es convaincu qu'elle va
offrir la chance de tes rêves qu'elle va
changer ta vie et faire de toi sa
productrice fouet
elle doit même pas se souvenir de ton
nom de sony s1 souvient enfin parfois je
suis là je veux faire du tri dans mes
affaires et donné les choses qui n'ont
pas l'étincelle de joie choix
c'est dingue cette fille arrive encore à
filer la chair de poule
alors grèce a dû repenser à la
proposition de résidence à las vegas en
fait je crois que le temps est venu
d'enregistrer un nouvel album
c'est une idée parmi d'autres
je suis censé lui dire quoi
je suis une simple petite assistance
mais j'aimerais devenir aux chroniques
gray davis n'a pas sorti de nouveau
disque depuis une décennie et les fans
nouvelles 1
laisse moi faire mon travail effectif
qui consiste à lui apporter son café ces
tampons ses mouchoirs et toutes les
conneries pour lesquelles tu es payé
depuis ces six derniers mois
tu es payé je croyais que tu étais
stagiaires ma vie je voulais pas vous en
parler ni à jack ni à vous j'ai fait une
maquette de l'album vous entend vous
savez bien qu'il ya un micro l'intendant
j'avais envie de tenter ma chance enfin
pour que tu prends une question de
confiance et de thé vous
l'histoire de la musique seulement cinq
femmes de plus de 40 ans ont une chanson
classé numéro 1 et une seule de ces
fameux thé noir c'est loin d'être fini
pour vous justement seraient ravis de me
voir donner le même concert tous les
soirs mais si je pouvais aspirer à mieux
je veux faire partie de l'aventuré
attends c'est ta voix tu oui faut que tu
demandes à ta bosse de togo menthe et sa
rive monsieur je voulais déjà dit on ne
fait pas de service à bord des véhicules
eh bien vous devriez ce serait une bonne
idée vous êtes grèce davis rang